bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour suivre les débats
dans l'hémicycle sur la transition
énergétique
les sénateurs s'attaque aujourd'hui au
coeur du texte l'article 1er qui fixe
les grands objectifs énergétiques de la
france avec un point d'achoppement
majeur le nucléaire d'un côté vous avez
le gouvernement qui veut ramener la part
du nucléaire dans le mix énergétique de
75 à 50% d'ici 2025 c'est d'ailleurs une
promesse de françois hollande
de l'autre les sénateurs de la majorité
qui juge cet objectif irréaliste
ils sont d'accord pour baisser la part
du nucléaire mais sans objectifs
chiffrés vous allez le voir ça va être
l'un des grands bras de fer de ce texte
tout de suite direction la séance pour
le débat oui madame la présidente madame
le ministre mes chers collègues
à cet instant le l'amendement de notre
collègue grumier et soumis au débat
je voudrais le défendre tout en
comprenant le travail diplomatique
judicieux pertinents à binh et maîtrisé
de notre rapporteur
ça c'est vrai rapporteur ses forces et
un porteur apaisé je les dis s'efforce
de concilier les points de vue mais je
trouve que l'amendement daniel grenier a
l'immense mérite de poser une question
de principe
madame le ministre pourquoi croyez vous
que les consommateurs consomme-t-il de
l'énergie eh bien je vais peut-être
surprendre monsieur dantec
mais ce n'est pas par perversité ce
n'est pas par souci de dégrader et
l'environnement
ce n'est pas pour le plaisir de gaz et
des émirs de revenus
substantielle mais c'est simplement
parce qu'ils en ont d'une part l'absolue
nécessité et que d'autre part dans une
économie de marché
des millions de décision assumée chaque
jour par des consommateurs privés ou
publics familiaux ou entrepreneuriaux
les conduisent dans un environnement
économique déterminée à choisir la
solution la plus rationnelle j'écoutais
madame jouanno à l'instant et nous parle
de l'ademe je comprends très bien le
volontarisme du gouvernement mais a
quand même un moment on peut se demander
si l'économie de subventions qui tord
les prix et qui nie les réalités
économiques peut être indéfiniment
supporté par notre pays la perspective
de diminuer de 50% la consommation
énergétique de notre pays
c'est une décision idéologique elle ne
correspond à aucune démarche rationnelle
à aucune analyse prospective
elle correspond simplement à l'idée
qu'on pourrait faire différemment que la
france serait exemplaire et
accessoirement parce que la france n'est
pas soumis à élection que le
gouvernement lui sera exemplaire au sein
de sa majorité et toutes ses composantes
de la majorité c'est pas du tout le cas
la consommation obéit à des lois qui
sont des lois économiques qui s'impose
au monde entier par exemple en effet
depuis 2008 nous avons un plafonnement
de la consommation électrique
mais lorsque l'on rentre dans le détail
de ce plafonnement
on s'aperçoit que ce plafonnement était
là c'est daniel gremillet à raison liée
à la très forte diminution de
consommation d'industrie majeur dans
notre pays qui ont diminué leurs
activités et qui ont par conséquent
diminuer leur consommation électrique
c'est un premier point
vous avez ensuite en effet la sphère du
logement mais il ya une question qui
devrait quand même posé un jour si
l'économie
d'énergie consommée dans le bâtiment et
rentable pourquoi diable faut-il la
supporter à grands coups de subventions
et d' avantages fiscaux c'est parce
qu'en réalité chaque consommateur nous
avez donné un exemple très spectaculaire
madame le ministre
il mériterait d'être regardé dans son
ensemble mais il y à 30 millions de
logements en france nous en construisons
moins de 300 milles actuellement est il
raisonnable chère chantal jouanno de
penser qu'il y aura cinq cent mille
runes rénovation actuellement la réponse
est non la réponse est non parce que
dans la priorité du pouvoir d'achat des
familles
il n'est pas pensable qu'elles
investissent dans un logement français
qui est aujourd'hui le logement le plus
cher en europe ce qui est
invraisemblable
alors que nous avons le territoire le
plus vaste et devrions avoir le foncier
le plus léger il n'est pas certain que
la priorité des familles sera de conso
de consacrer sauf s'il y sera obligé par
la règlement a mobilisé des sommes
importantes en termes d'économie
d'énergie parce qu'elles font elles
mêmes l'arbitrage entre la dépense qu'il
faut pour économiser quelque chose et le
retour sur investissement vous avez dit
madame le ministre et je terminerai
qu'il y à des économies d'énergie dans
l'industrie mais c'est évident c'est
évident il y a de la chaleur qui part
dans tout les fumées du sinn simplement
la rentabilité des investissements n'est
pas à la hauteur en train une société
idéale et une société que l'on peut
s'offrir il y à un moment il faut
laisser respirer l'économie et laisser
la liberté aux décisionnaires c'est la
raison pour laquelle sur le plan des
principes je défends l'amendement de mon
collègue daniel dremière je vous
remercie alors monsieur delattre voulait
parler oui c'est ça
vous y prendre la parole je vous en prie
je remercie madame la présidente du chat
collègues osé écrire dans un même
article que l'on va réduire de 30% la
consommation des énergies fossiles en
2030 par rapport à 2012 et réduire en
même temps la part du duvet
la production d'écrits la production
d'électricité à 50% à l'horizon 2025
alors qu'on est aujourd'hui à 75 %
relèvent plus mes chers collègues de la
philosophie que des réalités économiques
de notre pays aujourd'hui l'alternative
sérieuse en termes de masse aux énergies
fossiles
c'est le nucléaire il faut bien sûr
encourager toutes les formes d'énergies
renouvelables les fixer des objectifs
dans la loi qui ne sont en réalité que
les termes d'un accord politique ne peut
que conduire à une terrible impasse pour
notre compétitivité pour nos emplois
pour l'avenir de toute une génération
on n'arrivera pas supprimer non plus
parce qu'en fait la réalité quand on on
fait le calcul il nous faudrait
supprimer deux centrales nucléaires par
an et je suis très surpris de constater
que personne ne parle du coût des
démantèlements ça coûte cher de
démanteler il y avait même des
amortissements qui a été prévu et ces
amortissements ont été au fil du temps
on va dire confisqué il serait plus
sérieux il serait plus sérieux car il
nous faut du temps d'envisager la
modélisation la remise à niveau des
centrales et investir surtout dans la
nouvelle génération et j'avais cru que
c'était un des objectifs de madame la
ministre je dirais aussi que nous sommes
tous ici élus locaux nous connaissons
l'étendue les dégâts du parc pas loin 30
millions de logements sont en difficulté
le point de vue la consommation
énergétique
il faudra donc du temps et encore plus
de moyens
en plus des incantations du possible et
à l'avènement des quartiers intelligent
parce qu'en fait c'est pas pour demain
mais quartier intelligent enfin le
nucléaire est une des activités
potentiellement exportatrices pour notre
pays
les cette défiance permanente nous
organisons sur le tard de la france ne
peut qu'handicapé la crédibilité de la
filière qui fut d'excellence j'ai eu
l'occasion de sa genèse le visiter daya
bay en chine la première centrale
nucléaire française qui fut un vrai
succès alors c'est bien dommage
dans le contexte actuel de la situation
économique industriel de notre pays
d'abandonner parce qu'en fait dès lors
que sur son propre territoire vous
abandonner l'idée même d''excellents' de
la filière vouloir exporter ce sera très
compliqué en plus contrairement à ce
qu'on entend le mix en europe
il inclut du nucléaire il y à des pays
qui sont dépourvus aujourd'hui de
nucléaire et qui envisage de construire
notamment le long d'une à l'ubs en
tchéquie en hongrie est naturellement
l'actualité oui le mx 6 1 6 1 inclut le
il inclut l'énergie nucléaire parce
qu'ils sont à côté eu des mines de
charbon et de ligne exploité par
l'allemagne
ils en subissent quotidiennement les
inconvénients c'est une réalité
le déni de réalité ne devrait pas
devrait nous inspirer aujourd'hui quand
on a ces situations alors pour toutes
ces raisons je pense que l'article 20
puisqu'on est dans les explications de
vote
à titre personnel naturellement je
voudrais compte les dispositions de cet
article qui ne correspond pas à une
réalité industrielle d'un pays mais qui
correspond à un accord politique qui
était conclue il ya quelques années et
tout le monde se souvient de 3,4
centrale on savait plus ce n'était pas
sérieux hier et ce n'est pas encore ça
lui aujourd'hui bien
alors monsieur de la toussaint c'est
l'explication son article nous en sommes
pour l'instant aux amendements mais
s'est fait comme ça c'est fait je vais
donner la parole à monsieur bourquin
l'ama et 1,6 et après aller non non
après chaque collègue j'ai entendu tout
à l'heure mon collègue remiller dix ans
la production industrielle a baissé et
vouloir faire baisser la consommation
d'énergie peut participer à la
désindustrialisation
j'ai envie de lui dire que la
désindustrialisation du pays a commencé
il ya 30 ans avec l'énergie la moins
chère d'europe
si si effectivement le coût de l'énergie
il faut défendre un coût de l'énergie
bas était l'unique cause la
désindustrialisation
on aurait remédié très vite à cette
désindustrialisation la
désindustrialisation les venues d'une
idéologie l'idéologie post industrielle
où on nous disait qu'il ne fallait plus
d' usine et il nous fallait des services
à la place et c'est ça la cause et donc
je pense que il faut prendre conscience
ici il nous faut prendre conscience ici
qu'une entreprise compétitive ce n'est
pas une entreprise énergivores on a
visité avec le premier ministre il ya
quelques jours les rénovations
d'ateliers il ya deux choses pour être
pour avoir de la compétitivité
bien sûr la robotique mais deuxième
chose les économies d'énergie qui sont
omniprésentes y compris dans la
réflexion des industriels et deuxième
chose
troisième chose le changement climatique
ne le voyais pas uniquement comme un
boulet à traîner
voyez le au contraire comme une chance
pour la france
une chance pour notre industrie pour
créer de nouveaux emplois
il y en a par exemple il y en a par
exemple dans les énergies renouvelables
il y en a aussi dans des techniques de
fabrication qui nous permettent
aujourd'hui d'avoir des produits presque
100% recyclable et avec des économies
d'énergie importantes
nous sommes au 21ème siècle essayons de
mettre en place
l'économie du xxième siècle avec y
compris les énergies du 21ème siècle le
nucléaire fait partie du mixte il faut
le défendre à hauteur on disait de 50%
se donne un objectif mais il doit y
avoir aussi d'autres énergies et vous
verrez par exemple que la question de
l'hydrogène si on règle le transport et
le stockage sera mais vous le savez très
bien
il faut que notre pays à ce niveau-là et
l'europe choix à la pointe de la
recherche pour que nous ayons les
brevets sur ses nouvelles énergies
donc je ne ne prenons pas cette question
comme un boulet à traîner
on va accueillir la conférence mondiale
du changement climatique
vous savez vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
cette conférence mondiale sur le
changement climatique doit doit nous
inciter à prendre justement pour des
raisons économiques et industriels
la tête de peloton de tête de la lutte
contre le changement climatique et avec
une volonté mais qui doit est
omniprésente c'est celle d'avoir les
industries de demain les industries de
demain cette start up qui vend des
panneaux solaires de nouvelle génération
au japon et qui fait un tabac au japon
et c'est une start up française une
autre start-up qui étaient devant nous
et qui nous qui nous montrait il y a
quelques mois qu'avec des halles qu'on
arrive à faire maintenant des carburants
de nouvelle génération qui nous
donneront à la fois à la fois beaucoup
de productivité si nous savons le faire
mais surtout chez les carburants de
demain
laissons vers les possibles et ne
restons pas sur des vieux réflexes
sinon nous allons être à la traîne du
développement industriel est à la traîne
à la traîne de la question du changement
climatique alors tout à l'heure mes
collègues disait faites attention
comment on est dans une situation
économique difficile
la production a dû ce qu'elle a montré
un regain
certes ce regard est fragile
mais si nous voulons avoir une
production industrielle c'est aussi avec
de nouvelles industries et les énergies
renouvelables les énergies renouvelables
et les économies d'énergie seront au
coeur de cette nouvelle croissance en
quelque sorte
il faut trouver une nouvelle croissance
et une croissance durable et c'est comme
ça que la france justement
réindustrialiser à son économie
et ça c'est un challenge qui est devant
nous est ce qu'on le prend ce challenge
est ce qu'on se dit on peut on peut le
faire
est-ce qu'on a la volonté de le faire et
si on a la volonté
mais vous savez très bien qu'on y
arrivera s'il ne se bouffe qu'à la
parole et à madame des ego merci madame
président moi j'ai bien écouté
madame le ministre et j'ai même entendu
quelques par son enthousiasme sur ces
questions je dis clairement mais enfin
mes chers collègues
moi je veux attirer votre attention sur
le fait que tout ça c'est extrêmement
théorique c'est de la théorie pure c'est
quoi au fond poursuivre nos objectifs de
réduction de la consommation énergétique
finale c'est quoi d'abord quelle est la
sanction si on le fait pas bien sûr on
sera tous l'an 2000 5 secondes pour le
voir évidemment bon mais quelques c'est
quoi la sanction s'est coincé
disposition c'est quoi ces dispositions
législatives qui consiste à mettre des
trucs en place et où il ya aucune
sanction
vous posez pas des questions là-dessus
moi je vais vous dire je crois que c'est
des bonnes intentions
c'est des bons sentiments selon
l'idéologie qui est la nôtre et ça
correspond à ce que j'ai dit
cette nuit au moment de d2 de l'article
1 et des prises de parole c'est des bons
sentiments c'est tout cdc les bonnes
intentions selon l'idéologie qui est la
nôtre c'est pas autre chose et je vais
mettre un peu plus sévère c'est de la
communication
voilà blême le ministre vous êtes dans
de la com vous êtes même le champion de
la communication c'est très fort là
dessus mais objectivement comme l'a dit
gérard longuet la consommation
énergétique ne s'est pas une résultante
c'est d'abord une raison
économique justement c'est pas un
objectif qu'on pouvait calé comme ça
quand vous annoncez puis tout va suivre
pas du tout d'abord vous demandez jamais
à quel prix c'est moi je suis dans la
commission des finances
la question que je me pose constamment
dans cet article
quel est le coot j'aimerais vous
entendre de vous poser cette question
en tout cas c'est de la communication et
je vous redis et pourquoi c'est la
communication
parce que c'est une résultante ça
dépendra de là où on en sera
comme l'a dit gérard longuet sur notre
économie mais c'est pas d'abord on
décide que la consommation est à tel
niveau mais ça tiennent pas debout
vous n'avez jamais fait d'économie c'est
pas possible madame lienemann vous avez
la parole
je crois qu'avec monsieur longuet madame
des ego nous avons un désaccord de mode
d'intervention de vision de l'avenir
quand vous décrivez la réalité telle que
vous la voyez c'est la main invisible du
marché c'est-à-dire chaque comportement
individuel va faire l'intérêt général
vous figurez vous monsieur longuet que
le général de gaulle doit se retourner
dans sa tombe
parce que toutes les grandes politiques
publiques
vous avez raison si on laisse faire le
marché si on ne prend aucune mesure
public
si on n'a aucun engagement collectif
nous ne réduirons pas la consommation
énergétique et nous ne réduirons pas les
gaz à effet de serre et donc il faut
prendre des mesures qui oriente le
marché qui fonde des politiques
publiques et qui pensent l'avenir avec
des objectifs qui mobilise elle public
et le privé
c'est ça qui est proposé est le
gouvernement raison de proposer les 20%
parce que si dès à présent nous ne
commençons pas à faire des mutations
technologiques indispensables si nous ne
faisons pas dans les arbitrages
d'investissements notamment dans le
monde dans la construction des efforts
en direction des technologies porteuses
économies d'énergie
à long terme on partage la compétitivité
et on n'arrivera pas à atteindre des
objectifs et je vais vous dire monsieur
longuet du point de vue économique que
nous avons intérêt à le faire quand
j'étais ministre du logement
j'ai proposé qu'on fasse des normes sur
la qualité du verre à faible émissivité
il vous a pas échappé que ceux qui ont
inventé le faire le verre à faible
émissivité c'était saint gobain
saint gobain avait à l'époque une grande
entreprise en france et dans votre
région
elle en avait une en allemagne pour
mille raisons de coût de je-ne-sais-quoi
qu'il fallait laisser faire le marché
on n'a pas voulu mettre des impôts
imposés les faire à faible émissivité
bilan des courses tous les emplois créés
par sa goda pour les verts à faible
émissivité c'est en allemagne et dans le
nord de l'europe est maintenant il va
falloir qu'on achète du verre venant de
ces pays parce que nous n'avons pas à
temps accompagner les mutations
technologiques
deuxième sujet économique quand vous
faites les analyses global de
l'investissement dans l'immobilier
il ya à la fois l'investissement sur le
foncier
l investissement sur la bâtie or que
vous faites là line l'aller la
comparaison entre les pays qu'on fait de
gros investissements sur la qualité du
bâti notamment pour économiser l'énergie
ils ont eu moins de spéculation sur le
foncier
parce que globalement quand vous avez
des sommes dans le marché pour vendre un
logement
si vous investissez sur le foncier vous
n'avez plus d'argent sur le bâti et que
nous on essaie d'orienter à ce que
l'investissement soit pas dans la rente
foncière mais bien sur le bâti parce
qu'il est productif productif d'emplois
productifs d'économie productive de
filières industrielles
alors oui cet objectif de 20% aérienne
est malade de ses coûts 20 % d'où ça
vient combien ça coûte
c'est la même chose que le plan climat
énergie au niveau européen
ce sont des objectifs qu'on se fixe en
commun qu'ils sont capables de mobiliser
la société et qui sont en elles-mêmes
parce qu'ils sont des objectifs partagés
porter d'arbitrage et non pas
chiffre qui ne font que coûte et mais il
porte aussi est notamment tva de grosses
recettes à venir pour l'état monsieur
rémy et vous avez la parole oui madame
la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues je pense que ce point
est un point qui devrait nous rassembler
nous rassemble est pourquoi le débat il
n'est pas sûr la part des 50% de la vie
de du logement du déplacement de la
consommation au niveau des ménages
le débat il est sur les niveaux
industriels et la part industrielle et
je dois dire à notre collègue martial
bourquin soit il m'a pas entendu soit
elle était distrait mais les chiffres
que j'ai donné j'ai eu le courage des
données depuis les années soixante
quinze que ça soit au niveau de l'emploi
des industriels que ça soit 10 de la
production énergétique que ce soit sur
la part industrielle dans le pib
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
sur ces 50 % personne ici qu'on soit du
milieu rural eu mes yeux robin ne peut
dire quelle que soit la région d'où on
vient
que nous n'avons pas besoin de retrouver
des emplois industriels
nous ne régleront pas le problème du
chômage dans notre pays si nous ne
retrouvons pas des emplois industriels
nous ne garderons pas le modèle social
dans notre pays si nous ne créons pas
des richesses je ne suis pas s'il vous
plaît je vous ai écouté je vous ai
écoutés je veux simplement dire qu'il ne
faut pas mentir mentir sur quoi on a
tous cette même ambition de retrouver de
l'emploi s'étant cet emploi qui va créer
des richesses qui me permettra
effectivement de garder ce modèle ce que
j'ai expliqué dans cet amendement c'est
quoi c'est d'expliquer que la base de
2012 n'est pas bonne elle n'est pas
bonne parce qu'on n'est pas dans la même
situation que d'autres pays parce qu'on
a effectivement perdu beaucoup trop
d'emplois industriels
et je suis d'accord avec là encore notre
collègue et martial bourquin
j'ai pas peur nous n'avons pas peur
c'est pas un boulet et je partage de
propos de madame la ministre
effectivement la transition énergétique
c'est une opportunité il mais ayons
l'honnêteté de reconnaître si on veut
partager horizon 2050 et g en coupe a
parlé des deux milliards d'êtres humains
en plus sur la planète
j'espère quand même que la france aura
l'ambition d'imaginer qu'elle pourra en
accueillir
j'espère imaginez que la france aura
l'ambition d'avoir aussi des parts de
marché dans cette nouvelle univers de
population horizon 2050
c'est ça le sens et le problème le
problème c'est l'amalgamme entre
l'ambition partagée sur les 50%
on se retrouverait tous et la
considération de la part économique et
notamment de la part industrielle et je
peux vous dire il n'ya pas un industriel
en france et je reprends le propos de
gérard longuet le premier euro économisé
contre y compris un air en efficacité
énergétique
mais il a la conquête en permanence
chaque fois qu'il fait un budget c'est
son souci premier
parce qu'il sait que c'est son prix de
revient derrière qui en découlent c'est
pour ça que je comprends pas qu'on se
déchire on devrait se retrouver et je
veux dire on conclure mon propos
on a besoin de se rassembler jeudi à
notre rapporteur ladislas la proposition
qu'il nous fait effectivement c'est de
dire il ya un objectif
le débat que nous avons eu dire
l'objectif y va être différent en
fonction des enjeux et des
problématiques
effectivement le 50% sur la partie
industrielle y est pas tenable
parce que s'il est dans la perspective
de 2050
ça veut dire que nous serons dans la
décroissance donc c'est pas possible si
on veut retrouver un emploi si on veut
garder notre modèle social
mais il ya eu la sagesse et c'est pour
ça que je vais retirer mon amendement au
bénéfice de sa rédaction
puisqu'il a la sagesse de dire
clairement de nous dire clairement
effectivement c'est un objectif à 2050
pour ma part j'aurais pas mis 50 % pour
la partie industrielle mais il la
sagesse de dire et de dire honnêtement
tout en préservant la compétitivité le
développement du secteur industriel
donc je retire ma demande je vous
remercie monsieur grémine et je vais
donc passer au vote
alors le premier amendement que nous
allons voter c'est le 686 rectifié bis
avec deux amendements
deux amendements deux avis pardon
défavorable
madame des esgaulx vous le maintenez
gérer
nous arrivons donc au 715 qui a été
défendu par monsieur dantec qui a aussi
deux avis défavorables
retirez vous aviez retirer le premier
pas le deuxième mais vous me retirer et
celui ci aussi très bien donc il reste
l'amendement 894 du gouvernement j'ai
été saisi d'un d'une demande pardon de
scrutin public par le groupe ump sur
l'amendement 894 je vous rappelle que
l'avis de la commission est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques instants
voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 95
sur l'amendement numéro 894 nombre de
votants 309 nombre de suffrages exprimés
280 pour l'adoption 131 contre 149
le sénat n'a pas adopté j'informe le
sénat que la commission de la culture
m'a fait connaître qu'elle a procédé à
la désignation des candidats qu'elle
présente à la commission mixte paritaire
chargée de proposer un texte sur les
dispositions restant en discussion de la
proposition de loi portant diverses
dispositions tendant à la modernisation
du secteur de la presse
cette liste a été publiée et la
nomination des membres de cette
commission mixte paritaire aura lieu
conformément à l'article 12 du règlement
je rappelle que monsieur le premier
ministre a demandé au sénat de bien
vouloir procéder à la désignation de
sénateurs appelés à siéger au comité de
surveillance de la caisse
d'amortissement de la dette sociale la
commission des affaires sociales a fait
connaître qu'elle propose la candidature
de monsieur jean-noël cardoux cette
candidature a été publié sera ratifié
conformément à l'article 9 du règlement
s'il n'y a pas d'opposition à
l'expiration du délai d'une heure nous
passons un article maintenant 938
monsieur cognette à nous à l'amendement
938 pardon messieurs poniatowski à la
parole cet amendement madame la
présidente a pour but de clarifier
l'objectif de réduction des énergies
fossiles
initialement défini en énergie finale
puis en énergie primaire pour retenir la
notion de consommation totale qui permet
de viser à la fois et sans risque de
confusion
madame la ministre les consommations
finales et les consommations
intermédiaires
merci madame la ministre votre avis
favorable je vais mettre aux voix le chu
young et je vous en prie oui merci
madame la présidente madame le ministre
mes chers collègues le seul à porter
j'ai envie de voter votre amendement
mais je voudrais une précision dans la
consommation s'agit-il de la
consommation nationale intérieur ou du
solde d'un compte de la production
totale considérez-vous par exemple
qu'une exportations d'énergie dans un
pays voisin constitue une consommation
nationale ou pas ma question n'est pas
complètement désintéressé complètement
neutre il faut savoir que sur la
production électrique française qui est
de l'ordre de ham l'ordre de 500
térawattheures annuel nous avons une
cinquantaine de tera watt heure qui
constitue un solde positif d'exportation
d'électricité jour à savoir si dans
l'esprit du gouvernement et l'esprit du
rapporteur
quand on limite la production d'énergie
est ce qu'on déclare également cour
décide de limiter le solde positif
d'exportation d'énergie
monsieur le rapporteur
il s'agit bien sûr chercheur à l'ong est
de la consommation nationale
point barre donc on peut vendre très
bien pas d'autres prises de parole je
mets au voile amendement 938 de la
commission présentée par monsieur
poniatowski avec un avis favorable du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient l'amendement est adopté
l'amendement 585 rectifié madame la mûre
oui madame la présidente
il s'agit là d' avoir des objectifs plus
réalistes
c'est à dire de porter la part des
énergies renouvelables à 20% au lieu de
23 en 2020 et à 27 au lieu de 32 en 2030
c'est également une manière de suivre
les recommandations de l'union
européenne d'un monsieur le rapporteur
alors madame la présidente oh oui cher
elisabeth j'étais un peu gêné par cet
amendement parce qu'il le visent que on
est bien d'accord
le thermique et l'hydro en prenant des
chiffres qui correspondent à des
chiffres qui pourraient inclure non
seulement le thermique et l'hydro mais
d'autres énergies renouvelables c'est
pour ça que j'ai comme je l'avais dit en
commission
j'ai recherché d'où pouvaient provenir
notamment ceux 27 % en 2030
madame la ministre j'ai dit au moment où
c'était en commission peut être
arriverez vous à m'éclairer mais mais
j'ai peur qu'il ya eu confusion entre
thermique hydraulique avec cet objectif
intermédiaire madame la ministre a dit
le rapporteur sur cet amendement avis
défavorable très bien quelqu'un souhaite
prendre la parole
madame la mûre c'est à dire qu'en
réalité je n'ai pas obtenu les
explications ni du rapporteur ni de
madame la ministre
moi mon objectif c'était d'être un peu
plus réaliste justement et de suivre les
recommandations de l'union européenne en
la matière ça veut dire que vous
maintenez votre amendement c'est ça
madame linda atteindre le ciel
rapporteur c'est justement dans les
chiffres de l'union européenne que je
n'ai pas retrouvé ces chiffres c'est
pour ça que j'étais embarrassée et c'est
la raison pour laquelle en définitive en
commission n'a pas fait les conserver
les objectifs du texte initial qui
concerne toutes les énergies
renouvelables en les déclinant par
grands secteurs et en leur adjoignant un
objectif de 10% de gaz renouvelables en
on s'est simplifié la tâche bien donc
j'y souscris et je retire mon amendement
très bien cet amendement faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune le 309 très
cliché tout d'abord avec monsieur qui
merci à la présidente mme amis des chats
collègues
le projet de loi de transition
énergétique est fixé comme objectif la
politique énergétique française
outre le nécessaire développement dr
giroux a bloqué nous sommes favorables
la réduction de la part de l'énergie
nucléaire dans le mix énergétique
français 52%
cet objectif pourrait traduire par sa
nature de plusieurs centaines plusieurs
centrales nucléaires
c'est qu'à part est totalement
irréaliste la cia nucléaire qui
représente un des fleurons d'un outil
française est un gisement non
négligeable d'emploi garantit
l'indépendance d'haïti la france et
contribue ainsi à assurer la sécurité de
l'approvisionnement en énergie de la
france objectif vie des articles alagna
5 d'articles premier par ailleurs quoi
qu'en dise le coût du nucléaire demeure
compétitif par rapport à celui des
énergies renouvelables grâce à un parc
légèrement amortie
or le prix de l'énergie est un élément
d'autant plus central que la facture
énergétique la france s'élève à environ
somme de dix milliards d'euros pam
nucléaire permet ainsi de produire de
l'électricité à des prix relativement
bas pays constitue un atout majeur à la
fois pour lutter contre la préserve la
précarité énergétique
et si que vous préserver la
compétitivité de nos entreprises en
scène les rivières présente comme un
avantage non négligeable d'être une
énergie décarbonée permettent à la
france de respecter ses engagements en
matière de pollution atmosphérique
aussi plutôt que d'envisager de réduire
l'uqtr il conviendrait d'encourager
l'innovation de cette filière afin de
développer des systèmes de nouvelle
génération qui permet une meilleure
utilisation de la ressource à des
rumeurs en uranium et qui respecte des
objectifs de sûreté nucléaire et le
roman durable grâce et nuire gestion des
déchets à durée de vie longue dont nous
proposons de nous de supprimer donc
c'est à cette année à 28
merci
alors le 586 rectifié madame la mûre oui
madame la présidente alors cet
amendement propose bien de réduire la
part du nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité à 50% mais cela à
l'horizon de la fin du siècle et c'est
pour suivre le la recommandation de
l'office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
qui a jugé qu'il fallait rééquilibrer la
production d'électricité en tendant vers
50 % d'ici la fin du siècle
en introduisant des énergies
renouvelables électrique couplé à des
moyens de stockage direct au fur et à
mesure de leur maturité technologique et
économique 717 monsieur dantec
on aura tout à l'heure un amendement sur
le fait qu'on fasse preuve de souplesse
sur les choix énergétiques pour l'est
pour les îles non connectés de moins de
2000 habitants
cela concerne notamment l'île de sein en
fait peut-être qu'il faudra étendre
l'amendement à un territoire d'un peu
plus de 60 millions d'habitants
puisque le débat nous avons actuellement
c'est un débat qui consiste à toujours
considéré que la france est en dehors du
monde donc c'est peut-être le moment il
2,5 il faut qu'on retravaille pour qu'il
s'applique à l'ensemble du territoire
français je crois qu'à un moment il va
falloir quand même qu'on arrête des
dettes dans dans quelque chose qui qui
est un peu hors sol qui est que le monde
aujourd'hui développe à marche forcée
les énergies renouvelables c'est le
chiffre que j'ai pu donner hier soir qui
est un chiffre de l' agence
internationale de l'énergie environ
d'ici 2020 1200 milliards
d'investissements dans le renouvelable
dans le monde
dans la même période l'investissement
sur le nucléaire sera à la louche et je
suis plutôt dans une estimation haute de
l'ordre de 120 milliards si la france
n'a pas une industrie extrêmement forte
sur le renouvelable
nous sommes marginalisés et quand je dis
marginalisés pour reprendre le débat
qu'on avait tout à l'heure sur
l'industrie ça veut bien dire que les 10
n de milliers de créations d'emplois qui
sont sur le renouvelable se créeront
ailleurs dans le monde et c'est ce qui
est en train de se passer et compris les
décisions totalement irresponsable pris
sous le gouvernement sarkozy de remise
en cause du cadre économique du
photovoltaïque
ça a été des dizaines de milliers
d'emplois de perdus ça a été une filière
clés à l'échelle mondiale sacrifié par
pur dogmatisme
c'est ça et aujourd'hui il s'agit aussi
de sortir du dogmatisme sortir du
dogmatisme c'est de dire il nous faut
une industrie forte sur le renouvelable
et il ne peut pas y avoir d'industrie
forte sur le renouvelable si évidemment
un nous ne la développe a pas en france
les 50% en 2025 et 2025 et une date qui
n'est pas hors sol c'est la date qui
correspond à la pyramide des âges du
nucléaire deux tiers des tranches
nucléaires françaises dépasseront les 40
ans entre 2020 et 2025
il s'agit donc bien avec le chiffre de
50% en 2025 de dire à peu près une
tranche sur deux sera prolongée a priori
de 20 ans à un coût de plus de 1
milliard la tranche c'est d'ailleurs
qu'on aura de toute manière pas les
moyens de plonger toutes les tranches et
on sait qu'on a des tranches dangereuse
donc on va passer un certain temps dans
les minutes qui viennent dans les heures
qui viennent sur ce chiffre il est tout
à fait raisonnable
il est tout à fait raisonnable il
correspond à une intégration européenne
il correspond à l'intérêt économique de
la france et correspond à la vétusté des
centrales françaises donc je pense qu'il
y aura beaucoup de dogmatique dans les
interventions mais effectivement c'est
50% en 2025 c'est tout simplement
rationnelle merci chantal jouanno à la
parole
merci merci madame la présidente alors
nous ne déposons pas un amendement qui
revient sur la question de la date ne
serait ce que parce qu'au sein de notre
propre groupe il ya peut-être beaucoup
de discussions sur le sujet delà de la
date à laquelle il serait souhaitable de
réduire la part du nucléaire à 50% dans
une proposition de résolution que nous
avions déposé en juin nous avions pris
la date de 2040 par contre ce que vous
que l'on vous propose mais un deuxième
amendement que j'y reviendrai juste
juste après ce que l'on vous propose
c'est de dire que cette belle
de la part du nucléaire doit être bien
évidemment proportionnelle à
l'augmentation de la part des énergies
renouvelables dans une logique qui est
d'assurer la complémentarité entre les
deux formes d'énergie et pour répondre à
plusieurs interventions qui ont cité le
modèle allemand comme un contre modèle
ou la développement des énergies
renouvelables se ferait au profit en
même temps des énergies fossiles pour
justement dire que chez nous on veut
deux types d'énergies décarbonées une
baisse du nucléaire mais une
augmentation du renouvelable
merci beaucoup le gouvernement un
amendement 893 madame la ministre
en effet sur un point tout à fait
sensible de notre de notre débat donc
par cet amendement je souhaite bien
évidemment rétablir l'horizon 2025 pour
cette réduction de la part du nucléaire
dans la production d'électricité de 115
% à 50 %
mais bien évidemment
dans le souci comme vous le disiez tout
à l'heure monsieur le sénateur de
construire des convergences et d'essayer
d'arrêter ensemble un modèle énergétique
qui puisse donner un signe clair en
particulier à nos entreprises puisque
c'est vrai que plus la représentation
nationale sera forte pour donner des
signaux clairs à nos entreprises plus
elles pourront investir avoir confiance
dans l'avenir calculés les retours sur
investissement calculé les durées
d'amortissement de leurs investissements
et construire ce nouveau modèle
énergétique tout en gagnant des parts de
marché à l'international
donc dans ce souci dans cette
préoccupation là le gouvernement fait
sien l'ensemble des critères qui ont été
travaillés et adoptée par votre
commission en particulier la façon dont
cette réduction de la part du nucléaire
va être accompagnée et surtout va être
conditionné donc il y a quatre éléments
qui ont été adoptées par votre
commission que je soutiens c'est pour ça
que je ne propose pas de les modifier
d'abord l'accompagnement de la monte en
puissance des énergies renouvelables
bien évidemment c'est une question
majeure puisque cette montée en
puissance des énergies renouvelables
c'est bien ce qui explique ce
rééquilibrage du mix énergétique qui va
nous rendre plus forts économiquement je
vais essayer de vous expliquer comment
deuxièmement le critère de
l'indépendance énergétique de la france
c'est un critère en effet majeur
gouvernement soutient cette précision
troisièmement le maintien d'un prix de
l'électricité compétitif
évidemment une pas question d'en
rabattre sur une énergie qui serait
compétitive pour la remplacer par une
énergie beaucoup plus cher et
quatrièmement donc il faut mais oui mais
c'est parce qu'il y aura au cours des
années aussi une montée en puissance de
la performance énergétique du
renouvelable et la baisse du coût bien
évidemment de la fabrication du
renouvelable et quatrièmement et
évidemment sans conduire à une hausse
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
comme on le voit chez les pays voisins
ou l'allemagne par exemple qui a renoncé
au nucléaire est obligé de rouvrir des
mines de charbon et des mines de lignite
ça n'est pas bien évidemment notre
modèle énergétique en revanche je crois
qu'il est important
de donner des signaux clairs c'est à
dire de fixer un cap
bien sûr que c'est un cas peu ambitieux
je le reconnais tout à fait 2025
mais est-ce qu'il n'est pas très
important pour nos grandes entreprises
énergétiques du secteur énergétique
d'avoir une visibilité claire est de
savoir ce que le pays veut en termes
d'objectifs je pense qu'il est important
pour la décision d'investissement les
décisions économiques et financières
dans les entreprises deuxièmement je
pense vraiment que organisé et fixer un
cap sur ce mix énergétique c'est un
atout très important pour nos
entreprises et pour notre filière
nucléaire elle-même
je rappelle comme je les dis en réponse
à la discussion générale que nous avons
une magnifique filière industrielle avec
edf areva et le commissariat à l'énergie
atomique et aux énergies alternatives et
nous avons vraiment la responsabilité et
d'ailleurs c'est leur souhait c'est leur
souhait c'est pour ça qu'elles ont
besoin de signaux clairs déchéance d'un
horizon de pourcentage pour qu'elle
puisse en effet prendre des décisions
stable et durable en termes
d'investissement et nous avons
absolument intérêts et elles aussi elles
sont en demande de règles claires pour
qu'elles investissent ce champ
industriel etc et ses marchés mondiaux
considérable sur les énergies
renouvelables
à titre d'exemple je vous rappelle que
des f vient de gagner la construction
d'une centrale photovoltaïque en chine
que c'est edf qui a construit la
centrale photovoltaïque qui se situer
sur le stade de la coupe du monde de
football au brésil et que de plus en
plus nos entreprises se positionnent sur
ces marchés les énergies renouvelables
et elles pourront d'autant plus vendre
leur technologie nucléaire qu'elles
seront en capacité d'offrir aux grandes
nations du monde qui sont aujourd'hui en
train de s'engager puissamment dans un
nouveau mix énergétique qu'elles seront
capables elle même aussi d'offrir un mix
énergétique et nous souhaitons bien
évidemment et cela a été dit aussi sur
tous les bancs de cette assemblée que
nous puissions aider nos entreprises à
devenir d un champion mondial des
champions mondiaux sur le domaine
énergétique et qu'elle puisse surtout
sur les marchés internationaux se
présenter en équipe et pas les unes
contre les autres comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui c'est quand je dois à
l'arbitré sur les halls et les offres
les appels d'offres sur l'éolien
offshore et que je dois je dois choisir
entre edf et gdf d'un côté areva alstom
de l'autre ça fait quand même bizarre et
donc contenant des entreprises aussi
sont en compétition sur les marchés
mondiaux
au lieu d'être unie de dudu ni de
rassembler leurs forces de mettre en
commun leur énergie au sens propre comme
au sens figuré
leur modèle de recherche etc elle serait
beaucoup plus forte sur les marchés
mondiaux
nous avons perdu un certain nombre de
marchés dans le domaine du nucléaire
abou dhabi par exemple sur les coréens
qui ont suivi centrale les etats unis
sont en train de se positionner à
l'égard de l'inde
je reviens de d'un double jeu participer
au sommet mondial sur le climat et le
premier ministre le nouveau premier
indien s'est engagé fortement dans son
mix énergétique puisqu'il va multiplier
par six l'énergie nucléaire et il va
construire et le programme énergétique
de l'img c'est de construire 100
gigawatts de photovoltaïque et 100
villes intelligentes
c'est à dire autonome en énergie et donc
les entreprises françaises elles ont la
démarche est considérable à conquérir
à condition qu'elle soit forte sur
l'ensemble des énergies et nous sommes
le seul pays à pouvoir offrir un mix
énergétique vers le seul pays allant des
entreprises qui soit à la fois
positionné sur le nucléaire est
positionné sur le renouvelable et donc
nous devons encourager nos entreprises à
accompagner et à profiter de cette
transition énergétique et certainement
pas à leur dire que rien ne doit bouger
et que le modèle français
c'est le toux ou le quasi tout nucléaire
parce que ça va se retourner contre nos
entreprises et donc quand on pense bien
faire mais moi je respecte l'opinion des
uns et des autres je respecte a fait
monsieur longuet vos opinions en plus
vous vous laissez les exprimer avec
respect c'est pas le cas sur tous les
bancs de cette assemblée
je respecte votre vos opinions et je
pense que en disant cela en faisant cela
vous vous pensez défendre avec bonne foi
le la place
la réputation de nos entreprises sur le
secteur du nucléaire
mais peut-être que justement on peut
défendre la réputation des entreprises
secteur du nucléaire en les poussant en
avant aussi en les encourageant à faire
en sorte qu'elles maîtrisent fortement
l'ensemble des technologies à la fois du
nucléaire du renouvelable et de la
performance énergétique
parce qu'aujourd'hui les grandes nations
qui font appel aux technologies
énergétiques pour engager leur mutation
énergétique et cela de façon accélérée
savent à toute allure aujourd'hui
l'évolution de l'evole l'évolution du de
la transition énergétique et ça va
s'accélérer
pascal approche de la conférence de
paris sur le climat aujourd'hui tous les
pays du monde doivent présenter à
l'organisation des nations unies leur
feuille de route sur la transition
énergétique
donc il va y avoir une compétition
mondiale industriel extrêmement forte et
je pense que le meilleur service à
rendre à nos grandes entreprises
énergéticienne c'est extrêmement clair
offensive ambitieux sur les perspectives
de rééquilibrage du mix énergétique et
c'est la raison pour laquelle tout en
intégrant parce que je pense que les
travaux de votre commission qui ont
énormément auditionné justement le les
entreprises et qui ont le souci votre
commission est le souci aussi d'être à
la fois crédible cohérente
et rassembler les critères qui peuvent
permettre d'éclairer les raisons pour
lesquelles lorsque l'on dit on passe de
75 à 50% ce n'est pas une remise en
cause du nucléaire
au contraire c'est une façon de
conforter notre filière nucléaire parce
que c'est une façon aussi de lui donner
les moyens d'investir dans les nouvelles
technologies du renouvelable en rendant
ces investissements rentables en rendant
service
ces investissements amortissable sur un
délai raisonnable en fixant un objectif
clair parce que si une entreprise n'a
pas d'objectif clair si elle se dit la
représentation nationale ne sais pas si
c'est la fin du siècle la moitié du
siècle 2025 2050
c'est très compliqué pour l'entreprise
après d'arrêter des stratégies
d'investissement des stratégies
d'amortissement des stratégies
industrielles des stratégies de conquête
de marché et c'est pourquoi il me semble
que nous devons à la fois accompagner
cette mutation la garantir
i m des conditions dont les quatre
conditions que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
qui sont issus de votre commission et en
même temps d'être clair sur les horizons
et sur les perspectives
sachant sachant que même si pour
certains je le comprends d'ailleurs ça
peut paraître ambitieux et rapproché il
y a dans le vote de cette loi aussi la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
c'est à dire la révision des objectifs
au fur et à mesure de la montée en
puissance mais si nous mêmes nous nous
mettons des freins ou si nous mêmes
avons l'air de douter dans la capacité
de nos entreprises à monter en puissance
sur le mix énergétique à conquérir les
technologies à investir dans la maîtrise
de l'offre de services et de l'offre
industrielle que l'ensemble des pays du
monde sont en train d'attendre à ce
moment là elles mêmes vont douter
d'elle-même
donc nous si nous sommes clairs sur nos
objectifs si nous sommes unis sur les
objectifs alors nos entreprises sont
allées plus forte au niveau mondial
j'aurai pour terminer dire que et je
reprends de cet exemple que j'évoquais
hier c'est qu'en revenant du sommet
mondial des énergies renouvelables à
abou dhabi dans un pays producteur de
pétrole
vous y étiez de certains d'entre vous y
était c'est quand même fascinant de se
dire qu'un pays producteurs de pétrole
organise le sommet mondial des énergies
renouvelables c'est à dire prépare
l'après pétrole et nous ne resterions
figé sur le modèle énergétique d'hier
non ce sont ceux qui vont anticipé
raisonnablement de façon maîtrisée mais
de façon volontariste et de façon
confiante dans nos grands industriels
qui sont aujourd'hui bien positionné
mais qui se font aujourd'hui dépassée on
le voit dans les attributions des grands
marchés mondiaux que nous pourrons leur
redonner confiance en eux et que nous
pourront accompagner cette transition
énergétique en créant le plus possible
d'emplois et de plus values industrielle
dans notre pays merci madame la ministre
madame jouanno le 622 rectifier oui
merci madame la présidente
dans la nouvelle rédaction de l'alinéa
28 il a été introduit une disposition
indiquant que la réduction de la part du
nucléaire là sans la fermeture des
centrales intervenez en fait sous deux
initiatives la première c'est
l'application duel 593 23 du code de
l'environnement et la deuxième c'est la
demande de l'exploitant le elle 593 23
c'est du bon sens c'est à dire c'est la
fermeture d'une centrale à la demande de
l'asn en cas de risques graves
c'est un cas je l'espère normalement
très exceptionnel la deuxième
la deuxième le deuxième facteur de
fermeture serait donc la demande de
l'exploitant
il me semble extrêmement mal venue que
dans une loi ou logiquement on est en
train d'expliquer que c'est le politique
que ce sont les pouvoirs publics qui
détermine qui décident de l'avenir du
mix énergétique
on renvoie à la simple demande d'un
exploitant l'opportunité de faire
évoluer ou non se mixer négliger
énergétique
donc nous avons déposé un amendement ou
nous supprimons justement ces deux
nouvelles dispositions merci beaucoup
le 194 rectifié bis gérard longuet oui
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues mon excellent
collègue pied a défendu avec verve
talent chaleur l'idée que je souhaitais
défendre qui est que le nucléaire n'a
simplement aucune raison d'être victime
d'un choix idéologique que ses
performances ne justifie en rien
performance du nucléaire vous les
connaissez et je voudrais rentrer un peu
plus en profondeur dans le choix que
vous faites
s'agit-il de plafonner à 50% la
production d'énergie ou les capacités de
production il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
le nucléaire ne représente que 49% des
capacités de production électrique de
notre pays
le thermique représente en gros 25%
l'hydraulique et le renouvelable le
solde jeu ma conviction est que nous
n'avons pas à mettre en cause cette
capacité et que nous devons nous garder
en particulier la possibilité d'un d'une
énergie nucléaire vivant pour notre
marché national et pour le marché
international
là où je suis madame le ministre en
désaccord total avec votre démonstration
c'est que si nous voulons une filière
nucléaire offensive au plan mondial et
vous avez cité par exemple l'inde
qui souhaitent s'équiper d'une vingtaine
de centrales nucléaires nous ne pourrons
le faire que si nous avons un marché
national vivant si ce marché national
vivant du nucléaire est soumis à un
risque politique majeur
il n'y a simplement aucune chance que
les industries des industriels
fusse-t-il public continue d'investir
pour le renouveau de ses produits
ils ne pourront pas investir non plus
sur la diversification de l'offre que
nous avions évoqué avec notre collègue
guillaume et qui est certainement une
des réponses le nucléaire est vu en
france à travers des unités importante
il y aura certainement une demande pour
laquelle nous sommes parfaitement
compétent et capable sur des unités plus
petites
il y a qu une seule règle c'est le bon
sens économique
si vous laissez la liberté économique
chère madame cher collègue lienemann
les investisseurs suivront si vous
soumettez la décision économique aux
risques politiques les investissent les
investisseurs iront ailleurs
et donc en imposant une barrière
politique à la vie du nucléaire vous
découragez totalement ce secteur
industriel pour les arguments liés à
l'économie décarbonée je reprends ce
qu'a dit mon collègue requis et il reste
simplement
arrêtons de politiser la vie quotidienne
alors que le bon sens économique existe
et pourquoi aurions-nous raison contre
tout le monde